باجماع السلطه والمعارضه شهدت تركيا اطول
اسبوعين في تاريخها ارتفعت خلالهما حراره
الانتخابات اردوغان الذي لم ينهزم في اخر
عشر انتخابات خاضها لجا الى سنان اوغان
اوغان الذي مثل كسب اصواته ما يشبه المزاد
لكن مشكله اوجان هي انه يقود تحالفا ولا
يمتلك حبا اصواته قد تتفكك وهو الذي تدعمه
اربعه احزاب يمينيه تشترك في خطوط
البرنامج العريض لكنها قد لا توافق سنان
في ميوله لاردغان الذي لا يلبي رغبات اقصى
اليمين
اعلن اننا ندعم المترشح رجب طيب اردوغان
في الدور الثاني من الانتخابات ادعو
الناخبين الذين صوتوا لنا في الدور الاول
لدعم المترشح اردوغان في الدور الثاني
حده المنافسه تزداد في الانتخابات التركيه
قبل ساعات من معرفه الرئيس الجديد وسنان
اوغان سيكون لاعبا مؤثرا في نتيجه
الانتخابات ينتمي للتيار القومي وحد اغلب
احزاب اليمين في برنامج واحد تمكن من
خلاله حصد مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت هذه
النسبه كان من المفترض ان تصوت المحرم
انجي غير انه انسحب من السباق بعد حصول
سنان على الاصوات كانت اول واهم شروطه
لدعم احد المرشحين هي اعاده ملايين
اللاجئين الى بلادهم السوريين تحديدا نقطه
تلتقي مع برنامج كريستار اوغلو والحزب
الحاكم هو الاخر لا يمانع الخطوه شرط
اوغان الثاني هو قطع العلاقه مع كل
الاحزاب التي تربطها علاقه مباشره مع
الاكراد وهذا شرط تعجيزي لكلى المترشحين
اردوغان يتمتع بدعم حزبه الدعوه مره
الكردي المعارض لحزب العمال الكردستاني
وهو ما يمثل واحدا في المئه تقريبا من
اصوات الناخبين كتله هامه ووفيه لن يتنازل
عنها اردوغان والامر الاكثر تعقيدا
بالنسبه لك الذي يحظى بدعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي المقرب من الاكراد حزب حصل على
8% من الاصوات في انتخابات 2014
ولا سبيل لاقصائه
[موسيقى]
لكن المفارقه انه وبعد اعلان اوزداك دعمه
تداول البعض على مواقع التواصل هذا المقطع
اذا فازت لجدار اوغلو ستحدث حرب من القائل
بنفسه
اذا فاز كلجدار اوغلو في الانتخابات سيكون
الفضل لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي ونظرا لانهم
يدعمون في انتخابات الرئاسه سيعملون لصالح
الارهاب باريحيه بدون اي رادع او مانع منه
في النهايه تحدث فوضى في جنوب شرق
الاناضول وتتجه بلديات حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لطلب المعونه من عده دول وعاقب
وصول المعونه الدوليه ستدخل تركيا في اتون
حرب داخليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات